what I hope to do in this video is give
ourselves a more intuitive sense of
probabilities so let's go back to an
example that we've seen before we're
rolling a fair six-sided die and so
there are six possibilities we could get
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 or a 6
now let's say we ask ourselves what is
the probability of rolling of rolling a
number that is less than or equal to
less than or equal to 2 what is this
going to be well there are six equally
likely possibilities in rolling less
than or equal to 2 well that means I'm
either rolling a 1 or a 2 so 2 1 2 of
the six equally likely possibilities
meet my constraints so there is a 2/6
probability of rolling a number less
than or equal to 2 or I could just
rewrite that as an equivalent fraction I
could say there's a 1/3 probability I
can go either way now let's ask
ourselves another question what is the
probability of rolling a number greater
than or equal greater than or equal to 3
well once again there are six equally
likely possibilities and how many of
them involve rolling greater than or
equal to three let's see one two three
four these possibilities right over here
the roll of three or four five or six
so four out of the six equally likely
possibilities or I could rewrite this as
an equivalent fraction as 2/3 so what's
more likely rolling a number that's less
than or equal to 2 or rolling a number
that's greater than or equal to 3 well
you can see right over here the
probability of rolling greater than
equal to 3 is 2/3 while the probability
of rolling less than or equal to 2 is
only 1/3 this number is a greater so
this has a greater probability or
another way to thinking about it
rolling greater than or equal to 3 is
more likely than rolling less than or
equal to 2 in fact not only is it more
likely you see that 2/3 is twice 1/3
this right over here is twice as likely
you're twice as likely
to roll a number greater than or equal
to three then you are to roll a number
less than or equal to two and you could
even see right over here you have twice
as many possibilities of the six equally
likely ones four versus two four versus
two here and so you say okay I get it
Sal you know if the probability is a
larger number the event is more likely
it makes sense and in this case it's
twice that the number is twice as large
so it's twice as likely but what's the
what's the range of possible
probabilities how low can a probability
get and how high can a probability get
so let's let's think about the first
question so how low how low can a
probability go how low so what's the
lowest probability that you can imagine
for anything well let's give ourselves
let's give ourselves a little bit of a
experiment let's ask ourselves the
probability of rolling of rolling a
seven well once and and pause the video
and try to figure it out on your own
well there are six equally likely
possibilities and how many of them
involve rolling a seven well none of
them it's impossible to roll a seven so
none of the six so we could say this
probability is zero and if you see a
probability of zero someone says the
probability of that thing happening is
zero that means it's impossible that
means and no in no world can that happen
if it's exactly zero so this right meet
here the probability is zero that means
it is impossible it it is impossible now
how high can a probability get so how
how high can a probability get well
let's think about let's say probability
of rolling rolling any number any number
from one to six well have six equally I
have six I have six equally likely
possibilities and any one of those six
meets this constraint I would have
rolled a number any number from one to
six including one and six so there's
equally likely possibilities and so the
probability is one and so if someone
says the probability is zero it's
impossible and if someone says the
probability is 1 that means it's
definitely going to happen going going
going it's definitely going to happen so
the maximum probability for anything is
1 the minimum probability is 0 you don't
have negative probabilities and you
don't have probabilities greater than 1
and then you might be thinking wait wait
you know I've seen things that you know
they look like larger numbers than 1 and
you're probably thinking of seeing this
as a percentage so 1 as a percentage you
could also write this as 100% this right
over here as a percentage is 100% but
100% is the same thing as 1 you can't
have a probability at 110 percent 110
percent would be the same thing as 1.1
now this is really interesting because
you would often see someone say hey you
know something for sure is going to
happen or something is impossible but
even a lot of the things that we think
for sure going to happen there's some
probability or some chance that they
don't happen so for example you might
hear someone say well what's the
probability that the Sun will rise
tomorrow well you might say it's going
to happen for sure but you got to
remember you know some type of weird
cosmological event might occur some kind
of strange huge planet-sized object in
space might come and knock the earth out
of its rotation who knows what could
happen all of these have a very low a
very low likelihood very very very very
very very low likelihood but it's hard
to say it's exactly what if I said the
probability that the Sun will rise Sun
will rise tomorrow tomorrow instead of
saying 1 I would probably say it's 0.999
and I would I would throw a lot I would
throw a lot of nines over here I
wouldn't say it's 0.9 repeating forever
and actually there's an interesting
proof stat 0.9 repeating forever
is actually the same thing
one which is a little counterintuitive
but I would say there's a very high
probability but even something is such a
high probability it's going to be close
to one but I won't say it's exactly the
one because there could be some kind of
quasar that blasts us with gamma rays or
who knows what might happen but it's a
very very high probability same same
thing you know the probability the
probability here probability that you
know my my my my pet my pet my pet
gopher my pet gopher could compose could
come could write the next great novel
writes writes a novel and actually not
just a novel a great novel just a novel
would be that impressive for Grover but
writes a great novel well once again you
know this gopher sitting there typing at
a keyboard it would seem somewhat random
but there is some probability that it
actually does it there's some chance it
does it so I would put this at a very
low and I would say it's exactly zero if
we had a an infinite number of Gophers
doing this forever who knows maybe one
of them might write that great novel in
fact if we had an infinite what number
doing it forever eventually a lot of
people would say it at some point you
would but it just one go over trying to
write a novel what's the probability
they write a great novel well I would
say it's pretty close to zero I throw a
lot of zeroes I would throw a lot of
zeroes here and at some point you might
have something like this so once again
not absolutely impossible but pretty
close to pretty pretty close to
impossible and so big takeaways higher
probability more likely the lowest
probability you can get to zero highest
probability is one if your probability
is more if you know when you talk about
coin flipping if you say the probability
of heads for a fair coin and you say
well that's one-half that means it's
equally likely to happen or not happen
so anything that has a larger
probability than 1/2 it's more likely to
happen than not anything that has a
probability less than 1/2 it's less
likely to happen than not